TUESDAY.
HE HAS LOST HIS LAST TWO.
HE
WE TALKED ABOUT KYLE CONNOR AND
HE'S ONROUGH.
GREAT SETUP BY THE  SCHENN, NOT
THIS, AND THERE WAS A LITTLE
E
HIS POINT STREAK TO FOUR GAMES
AND WITH THE HELLEBUYCK.
O'REILLY AWAY
FROM HELLEBUYCK AND JUST WIDE.E.
>> Darren: TOO BAD THAT PASS BY
SAAD KIND OF HANDCUFFED NIKO
MIKKOLA BECAUSE THAT
MIKKOLA.
WINDS, TIPPED, BLUES MARCH
FORWARD WITH JUS THAT IN DEEP,
BUT FAULK TRIES A DEFENSE
IS GOING LET'S MAKE SURE THE
PUCKS GO NORTH AND NOT GET
BETWEEN THE LEGS AND THE BLUES
QUICKLY TO CENTER ON THE PARAYK.
LATE HERE IN THE PERIOD, THAT
PASS OFF T OF IT AND
I THOUG
DUBOIS, RUN DOWN BY SCANDELLA,
AND THEN'S PASS OFF ABROWN.ER T
HERE'S'S TONIGHT.
NOW TOROPCHENKO AGAIN.
KRUG IS WIDE OPEN,
FACE-O
CENTER BY STANLEY AS HE STEPPED
AND HE WOULD LIKE TO SEE
BIG TOROPCHENKO TAKEEN.
PLAY BEHIND THE NET.
SCANDELLA HAS THE PUCK RIGHT
THERE.THERE,
KEEPS IT ALIVE FOR THE MOMENT.
AND NOW IT'S CONN GET AWAY FROM
DeMELO.
MORRISSEY OFF.
AND NOW FOR PERRON, GOES
OVER TO TARASENKO, QUICKLY DOWN
THERE O O
THE CORNER.
NOW SCHENN.
POINTS TONIGHT, 496 POINTS, TIES
THE GREAT ALEXANDER STEEEE
GOAL.
BINNINGTON MISSED IT.
AND NOW SCHEIFELE GETS AWAY FROM
THE HIPWAS ABSOLUTELY
ACK IN, EHLERS, AND
THEY SCOR